yes Nigel Adams you'll recall is one of
Boris Johnson's closest lieutenants
going back years
um he has been with Boris Johnson so
Nigel Adams along with people like Jake
Berry and others one of Boris Johnson's
closest allies and supporters and this
is beginning to look like a coordinated
uh campaign of resignations first of all
we had uh we had Nadine Doris last night
now Nigel Adams now Nigel Adams is MP
for Selby and Einstein in Yorkshire
pretty safe seat just over 20 000. he's
been an MP uh since 2010 under Boris
Johnson he had a few middle ranking
cabinet posts that's ministerial post he
did at one stage attend cabinets
although he wasn't a full member of the
cabinet now Nigel Adams of course was
one of those tipped for a peerage
although whenever I asked him about he
always claimed he knew nothing about it
uh but he did tell me that he told his
Association as a year or so ago he did
not intend to fight the next general
election now until a few minutes ago it
looked as though he would stay on as the
MP for sale being aimed until the
election and then go now in his
announcement he says that yesterday
Selby conservatives selected an
excellent new parliamentary candidate
and he says I have today informed the
chief whip at Simon Hart that I will be
standing down as a member of parliament
with immediate effect
it has been an honor to represent the
area where I was raised educated and uh
and um
and grew up and and so on so we Face the
prospect now of a trio of by-elections
what a nightmare for Rishi sunak so
we're here in the uh Uxbridge and west
ruislip constituency where the labor
party I can tell you have wasted no time
in sending in activists MPS and of
course their local candidate to do some
campaigning this afternoon the second
by-election uh this is obviously Boris
Johnson was Boris Johnson's seat not
anymore the second is Nadine Doris's mid
bedfordshire seat that's a safe Tory
seat uh the liberal Democrats have been
there today campaigning are we going to
see some unofficial moves here where
labor concentrate on this seat and
perhaps the lib Dems concentrate on the
Bedford to see and now we have a third
Selby and Ainsley where Mr Adams I said
a majority just over 20 000. you would
expect probably Boris Johnson would want
to get these by-elections over with as
soon as possible so we're perhaps
looking at Late July and probably hold
them all on the same day there will be
trepidation however in the Tory High
command how many more Boris Johnson
allies are going to step down uh you
remember when Boris Johnson was prime
minister we had Sajid Javid went and
then minutes later Rishi sunak went that
followed Oliver Dowden going is uh are
they going to be more resignations after
these three so it's looking like a
coordinated campaign with Boris
Johnson's allies basically saying to
Rishi sunak we've had enough we've had
enough of your government we saw what
Boris Johnson said in his long uh Angry
statement last night we haven't had any
long angry statements yet from either Mr
Adams or Nadine Doris she's been
relatively circumspect by her standards
over the last 24 hours but we've got a
by-election crisis now for uh
although his allies will say two of
these three seats are relatively safe
over twenty thousand majorities but the
liberal Democrats let's not forget
overturned big majorities similar to
that that and Doris had in 2015 in mid
bedfordshire in Shropshire North
following the uh demise of Owen
Patterson and secondly in uh Tiverton
and Honiton down in Devon remember Neil
Parish the MP who claimed he was looking
at tractors on his uh on his computer
well I think folks don't think it was
quite a tractors that he was looking at
do you remember that story anyway here
we are in Hillingdon in the Boris
Johnson's constituency where labor is
already campaigning they would hope to
re to overturn that Boris Johnson
majority of seven thousand what about Mr
Johnson
in his statement last night he said I'm
quitting for now will he try and get
Henley back the MP there John Howell
standing down will he perhaps try to go
and try and fight her
um the uh the mid bedfordshire or even
Selby and Einstein probably not and it
has been appointed out of course that
the reason for his quitting this report
that looks as though the committee and
privilege is throwing the book at him
um
even if he quits as an MP the report
will still come out he will still be
damned as having lied to Parliament so
Mr Johnson you could say his reputation
is in tatters and he is angrily walking
away and the breaking news is that one
of his closest allies Nigel Adams has
now joined another Ally Nadine Doris in
walking away from parliament's plunging
Rishi sunak into a triple by-election
challenge
and John these are quite incredible
times we're seeing aren't they and who
knows you know we've had three going
within 24 hours before the end of the
day might get another
it's possible yeah I mean look thinking
about uh Mr Johnson's closest allies one
would think of someone like Jake Barry
for example he's a MP for Rossendale and
Darwin in Lancashire uh coincidentally
that's a feat a seat that Nigel Adams
stood in unsuccessfully before he became
MP for Selby and Ainsley
um
might he's a former party chairman he
has been pretty critical of the current
government
the other really close Boris Johnson
allies are people like are people like
um uh Ben Wallace for example I don't
think he's about to quit the defense
secretary uh that would be extraordinary
in the middle of the Ukraine crisis and
of course he has been tipped as a
candidate uh to be the next NATO General
Secretary he has recently
stated that he is interested in that job
so
Jake Berry perhaps
um the likes of Jacob Reese MOG unlikely
to stand down we've heard today of
course that the veteran Euro Skeptics
are bill cash is standing down that's a
fair he is 83 years old I'm told that he
has been considering standing down he
finds the traveling between his
Staffordshire constituency and London
um a bit of a strain now that he's 83
years old so it was not unexpected that
sir bill cash aged 83 would announce his
retirement